[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Merhabalar
bazı kadın sözler vardır 100 yıl hatta
bin yıllardan aktarılarak Bize gelen
yaşadıkça hayatta karşılığı olduğunu
düşündüklerimden biri de her şerde
vardır bir hayır gençken bu tür genel
geçer sözlerden hiç hoşlanmaz bunların
insanları pasifliğe ittiğini sonunda da
teslimiyete ittiğini düşünürdüm ama
aslında öyle değil yaşadıkça da bu Kadim
sözlerin Aslında etkili bir başka
aldırışın dönüştürücülüğün gizli
olabildiğini gördüm Buna rağmen bu Kadim
sözlerin her zaman geçerli
olmayabileceğini de mesela ölümcül
felaketlerde ya da savaşlarda onca insan
giderken ağaçların dimdik durmasına
rağmen insanlar hayvanlar Yıkıntıların
altında kalırken nasıl bir hayır
olabilirdi ki
benzer şekilde
Canlar aynı ırk ve dinden insanlar
birbirlerini öldürürken nasıl bir hayır
bekleyebilirdi ki insan
takvimler 2020'nin ilk aylarını
gösterdiğinde Çin'de İtalya'da kovit
vakalarında haber bültenleri giderek
daha fazla yer veriyordu
Böyle bir dönemde yepyeni bir döneme
girerken dünya saatlerin durduğu yeni
bir döneme girmek üzereydi zaten çevre
felaketleriyle alarm veren yerkürenin ve
tükenen diğer canlıların sesini
dinlemeyen İnsanoğlu
2020-2022 döneminde önce yüksekten önce
yüksekten bakan tavrına rağmen susup iç
muhasebesini yapmak zorunda kaldı ve
gördü ki insanoğlunun birkaç ayda bile
tekrar
kirliliğinin olmadığı bir dünyada dünya
birkaç ayda bile kendine gelebilmişti
birbiriyle husumet içindeki ülkeler
hastalığa şifa olmak için ortak
mücadelede birleşti rutinlerin
kıskacından çıkıp sabah uyandığında
penceresindeki kediyi köpeği
sardunya'nın elini sıkamadığı komşusunu
kıymetini daha çok anladığı insan
ölümcül virüs karşısında fakir zengin
Rus Amerikan Türk İngiliz Yahudi
Hristiyan Müslüman sarışın esmer
eşitlendi Tüm insanlar 2020 yılı Mart
ayında ülkemizde de kovid 19 vakalarının
görüldüğü zaman
günlük hareketi 30 bine yakın insan
trafiğinin olduğu 3000 kişinin çalıştığı
bir ağır sanayi şirketin ceo'suydum
pandeminin yarattığı aşırı belirsizliği
ve depresif ortama rağmen kendimizi
kaptırmadan hayata yeniden bağlanarak
paydaşlarımızın en zor zamanlarında
yanlarında olmuş satışımızı %50'nin
üzerinde arttırmış 5 kıtada binden fazla
satış noktasına ulaşabilmiş ihracat
pazarımızı 90 ülkenin üzerine
çıkarmıştık
Harekete Geçmek hayal kırıklığı anında
en iyi savunma mekanizmanız olabilir
burada bilinçsizce yapılan harekette
bereket var gibi girişimleri
kastetmiyorum Tabii ki bilgi ve tecrübe
ile stratejik hareket edebilen
akılcılığı bir bilinç ve Lider dahilinde
geçmiştekinden çok daha fazla
birbirimize bağlıyız artan karşılıklı
etkileşim tüketici ya da herhangi bir
karar verircinin aynı anda çok daha
fazla değişkeni bir arada
değerlendirmesini gerektiriyor Artık iş
modelleri de hayatta çok daha fazla
sofistike aynı anda çok farklı
disiplinlere birbirinden farklı
parametreleri bir arada düşünebilmeniz
gerekiyor Bu Eylem pandemi öncesinde
Zaten güçlüydü pandemi farklı ülkelere
ortak Hayati kaygılarla birleştirirken
çözüm için Kolektif düşünebilmenin
önemini de arttırdı
resimde gördüğünüz
ayakta sizi selamlayan benim halam
görülebiliyor mu bilmiyorum namı diğer
didoş 2021 Mart ayında
Göreve yeni başladığımda genel müdürü
olarak halam halam 91 yaşında çiçeği
burnunda bir şampiyondu
tahsildaroğlu'nda tevriyeye gelen bir
kişiden aldığım kavit 19 virüsü
tedbirli olmamıza rağmen halama geçtiği
için 10 gün sonra kaybettiğimiz didoşum
o sırada aynı sebepten hastanede hayat
mücadelesi veren eşim ve bana haber
veremedikleri için Sessiz Sedasız
defnedilen didoşum
Hayat bazen kontrolünüzde gelişmiyor
bizzat aldığım tedbirlerle 30.000 kişiye
tehlike yaşatmadan geçirdiğim pandemi
bir yıl sonra tarihte hayatımı altüst
etmişti
çok sınandım hastanede eşimin sağlığına
ilişkin kaygımın ardından taburcu
edilmeden önce sakinleştiriciler
eşliğinde yara anne gibi gördüğüm
didoşumun ölüm haberini aldığımda
o sırada kalkmak zorundaydım
hastalığın yaptığı tahriban sayesinde
kan dolaşım sistemi kalbim karaciğerim
başta olmak üzere tüm organların zaten
çok yorgundu her şeye rağmen ayağa
kalkmak gerekiyordu ayağa kalkmam sadece
kendim için değil hala hayat mücadelesi
veren eşim ve Kendi Ayakları üzerinde
durmaya çalışan Çocuklarım beni seven
herkes için gerekliydi
tüm acıma rağmen ayağa kalktım
2021 yılında tahsilleri onda tekrar işe
döndüğümde tüketicinin tercihlerinde
hala pandeminin etkisi sürüyordu hijyen
ve sağlık 1 derecede önemliydi her şeyin
çok hızlı değiştiği bir dünyada
bugünün tüketicisi vs kuşağı bunun
anlaşılmak istiyor Tüketiciyi ve onun
içinde bulunduğu dinamikleri
anlayabilmeniz için ürettiğiniz malın ve
teknik
bilgilerinin yanı sıra onun
tüketicinin de dilinden anlayabilmemiz
ihtiyaçlarını bile bilmeniz çok önemli
Dolayısıyla satabildiğinizi üretmeniz
gerekiyor ürettiğinizi satmak değil
başarıyı yakalayabilmeniz için iyi
Mühendisler kadar çok sayıda
bileşeni parametreyi değerlendirebilecek
finansçılara da iyi bir veri analitiğine
iş birimleri arasındaki koordinasyona da
çok ihtiyacınız var keza pazarlama aynı
şekilde
tüketicilerin nabzını çok iyi
Tutabilecek olan pazarlamacılara da
2008-2009 krizini hatırlayalım küresel
kriz dönemleri Aslında
canlı bir laboratuvar ortamı da sunar
Nitekim o tarihlerde macinza gibi dünya
çapında danışmanlık kuruluşlarının
yapmış olduğu çalışmalarda görüldü ki
kadınların yönettiği şirketlerin risk
yönetimleri ve kriz yönetimleri
diğerlerinden açık ara başarılıydı
benzer bir görünümü
2020-21 pandemi döneminde
Almanya ve Yeni Zelanda yöneten kadın
liderler ve kriz ekonomik kriz döneminde
fet eski başkanı bayan Yalanın başarılı
yönetiminde de görebiliriz
bu
performansı çok büyük ölçüde Aslında
kadınların çok farklı açılardan ve daha
çok Kolektif düşünebilmesine Aslında
birazcık borçluyuz 21 yüzyılda insan
toplumlarının ve dünyanın bekası için
sorunlara ve çözümlere eş Anlı olarak
Multi disipliner yaklaşmak gerekiyor
Buna ek olarak farklı bakış açıları
farklı yetkinliklerin karar ve yönetim
süreçlerinde değerlendirilmesine ihtiyaç
var
pandemi yaşanmasaydı bile dünyadaki
ekonomik sistemlerin devamı için de olsa
kadının karar süreçlerine ve masaya
davet edilmesi gerekiyordu niçin
dünyanın düzeltilmesi ve küresel
sistemin krizlerden çıkabilmesi için
farklı düşünce yapılarına farklı
kabiliyet ve tarzlara ihtiyacınız var
Yeni dönemde egoyu bir tarafa koyup
Kolektif düşünebilmeniz kapsayıcı
olabilmeniz gerekiyor
karşılıklı diyaloğa iş birliğine
kadınların soft powerına daha çok yer
açmalıyız kadın yönetici olarak
2001-2021 yılında göreve tekrar
başladığımda tedarik ve üretimden
başlayarak tüm süreçlerimizi ve
ürünlerimizi gözden geçirdik
sağlığı peynirimizin lezzetiyle
buluşturmak için anti inflamatuar
özellikleri olan yeni bir peynir
çıkardık Türk kaşarını üretmeye başladık
Zerdeçal ve karabiberle
zerdeçal doğada antinhar yani iltihap
çözücü özelliği en yüksek olan bir
Probiyotik ve aynı zamanda
probiyotikleri yaşatan bir previatik biz
zerdeçal karabiberli taze kaşarı
çıkardığımızda sadece Türkiye'nin değil
dünyanın da Aslında ilk zerdeçallı
peynirini yapmış olduk ardından buna saç
dökülmesine
herhangi bir Hani ürünün tanıtımı gibi
olsun istemiyorum ama yaratıcılık
açısından
keza uzakta zihin açıcı olarak
kullanılan bir veriyeye daha kekiğine
Karabiberi ekledik
başa dönersek her şerde vardır bir hayır
giden canlarımızı yerine koyamayız erken
gidenler canımızdan can olanların
acısını bıraktığı boşluğu ancak
yaşayanlar bilir
özlemlerimiz hayal kırıklıklarımız bizi
yine de kalanın en iyi evril olması ve
en iyi halimizi gerçekleştirebilmek için
alıkoymamalı hayat dinamik ve Aslında
konsantre olduğumuzda o anda Eğer
yılmışsak yenilmişsek dezavantajlıysak
dönüştürücü gücümüzü ihmal edebiliyor ya
da tam kullanamayabiliyoruz
Oysa en büyük başarılar en destansı
zaferler en zor koşullarda Çıkmamış mı
Kurtuluş savaşımız gibi
resimdeki Benim dedem arkadaşlar
yardımcı olacaktır herhalde Pardon değil
resimdeki benim Dönem Osmanlı ordusuna
en az 12 yıl yemen'de
sonrasında Çanakkale'de savaşmış sevgili
atasıyla memleketini savunmuş dile
koyalay atamızın izninde Ne Savaşlar
kazanmış yokluklardan Ne Büyük başarılar
elde etmiş Şanlı bir neslin memleketin
çocukları torunlarıyız küresel ekonomide
karşımıza zaman zaman çok zorluklar
çıkıyor ama bunları dönüştürebilmek
mümkün gençlere tavsiyem asla olmaz
demeyin ve tüm Zorluklara rağmen
iyiliğin tecellisi için gücünüzü
küçümsemeyin daha iyi hayal edin ve
dirayetli olun her ne yapacaksınız yapın
Kolektif düşünmeyi ihmal etmeyin
bireysel olarak gerçekleştiremediğiniz
çok şeyi aslında Kolektif akıl ve
emeklilikle gerçekleştirebilir çok büyük
başarılara imza atabilirsiniz
6 Şubat 2023 günü yoğun iş gündemi olan
yeni bir haftanın sabahı eşimden aldığım
acı haberi
Maraş'ta büyük bir deprem olmuştu
felaketin boyutunu bilememekle beraber
bölge insanı için çok kaygılanmıştık
yine de o sabah 11 ile kapsayan bu büyük
felaketi en hızlı yardımı oluşturabilen
sivil bir insiyatifi kuracağıma ilişkin
en ufak bir fikrim yoktu bazen Siz
önceden hayal etmeseniz bile Hayat size
empoze eder işte o zaman sizin gerçek
kişiliğiniz değer yargılarınız gerçekte
kim olduğunu öne çıkar
iş hayatındaki İlk Yuvam Sermaye
Piyasası kuruluğundan meslektaşlarımızla
kurduğumuz gruba genç bir arkadaşımızın
Hatay'da 30 yakınının kaybettiğine
ilişkin bir mesajı düştü
ve ardından Geçmiş olsun taziye
mesajlarımız kendisinin ailesinden
bulunduğu yere ihtiyaçlarını gruba
yazmasını istedim birileri her halde
liderliği alır yardıma yardımlar
organize edilir Ben de zaten çok sıkışık
olan günlük rutinime dönerim ama ne
yapar ne eder katkıda bulunurum diye
düşünüyordum
kriz yönetme tecrübesi kazanmış bir iş
insanı olarak çok hızlı hareket edilmesi
gerektiğini
düşünürken
saatler hızlıca geçerken ve peş peşe
artçılar yıkıma devam ederken
ilk etapta gelen reaksiyonların herhangi
bir harekete geçişi işaretlemediğini
fark ettim taze ile Geçmiş olsun
mesajlarımızın ötesine geçemediğimizi
görünce bölgedeki depremzedelere yardım
amacıyla ayrı bir grup kurdum ve hızlıca
destek verebilecekleri çağırdım depremin
ilk günü kontrolünü ve hızlıca analiz
olabildim diye kurduğum Grup bir gün
içinde kapalı olmasına rağmen 200 üyeye
dayanmıştı bile hızlıca Mersin'den satın
yapılacak yola çıkaracak şekilde ilk
yardım kamyonumuzun lojistiğini
olağanüstü hal için izinleri organize
ettiğimizde 7 şubattı proforma satın
alma işlemini tamamlayıp kamyonu 3 saat
sonra yani 2 gün içinde gün önceden
hataya ulaştırmayı hayal ederken
aramızdan bir arkadaş yardım kamyonların
bölgeye alınmadığı ve benzeri sebeplerle
sevkiyattan Vazgeçelim dedi Oysa
hazırlıklarımız tamamdı Hatay'a
Mersin'den sevkiyat yapacaktık yasal
izinlerimiz de alınmıştı asgari
koşullarımız hazırken tereddütle geçen
her saat her dakikanın maliyeti çok
büyüktü ikinci geceyi bölgeye gidecek
ilk yardım olacağını yola çıkmamamız
durumda
köydekilerin köydeki ölülerin vakaların
sayısında da artacağını izinlerimizde
olduğu için Aslında çıkmamamızın bir
sebebi olmadığını kararlılığımızı
bozmamanız gerektiğini izah etmekle
geçirdiğimi çok iyi hatırlıyorum üçüncü
günün sabahı ertesi gün grupta yol açık
yol açık diyerek bireysel satın alma
işlemini Kollektif şekilde tamamlamaya
ve sevkiyatı yapmaya karar verdik
Mersin'den çıkan kamyonumuz Hatay Deli
Çayı akşam saatlerinde ulaştı ardından
gönderdiğimiz ek yardımlarla Hatay
deliçay'a ilk 5 günde 5 ayrı sevkiyatı
başarıyla gerçekleştirmiş gıdadan hijyen
malzemesine ayakkabıdan battaniyenin üst
giyimden iç giyime çadıra ilaca Hatta
doktorlara bölge her türlü yardım
gidebilmesini sağlayabilmiştik grupta
birbirini tanımayan çok sayıda
arkadaşımla uyum içinde Milyonlar
mertebesinde alımı koordineli yapmış
sadece deli çayın değil çevresindeki 10
köyün de acil Hayati ihtiyaçlarını
karşılayabilmiştik gönderdiğimiz ilaç ve
sağlık gereçleri sayesinde gönüllü
Doktorlar da o bölgeye sevke olmuş ilk
5-6 günde 20 civarında açık ameliyat
gerçekleşmişti afet koşulları altında
ameliyatları yapan 11 köyde yaşayanların
sağlık kontrollerini gerçekleştiren tüm
sağlık görevlilerimize Ayrıca
minnettarız deli çay ve çevresine yardım
sevkiyatını ulaştırdığımız kareleri ve
mutlu resimleri gördüğümüzde Son 5 günde
yardımları yetiştirebilmek için
dakikaları kovalarcasına
yaşadığımız stres ve yoğun sorumluluk
hissine karşın içimizin ve gözlerimizin
nasıl ısındığını size anlatamam
felaketin olmasını sade vatandaş olarak
engelleyemezdik ama topyekün yaşanan
trajedi karşısında çöken ruhumuzu ayağa
kaldırdığımızda yardım götürebilmişlik
yol açık yol açık olarak uzman
arkadaşlarımızın gönüllü çabalarıyla
üniversite öğrencilerinin yurt içinde
yurt dışında burs kabul almalarına
yardımcı olduk sadece Hatay'da değil
aynı zamanda sonrasında Gaziantep
Nurdağı İslahiye arkada bazı görseller
var diye biliyorum
Islahiye Adıyaman Besni ve daha çok
sayıda Maraş Elbistan çok sayıda hata
bölgeye yardımlarımız gitti arzusu
Samandağ ve Defne ağırlıklı olarak da
devam etti
çok sayıda çocuğa anneye teyzeye amcaya
süt veren büyük başa üreticiye
ulaşabildiğimiz için onların hayatta
kalma ve hayata tutunma mücadelesine
destek verebildiğimiz için yaşadığımız
yoğun duyguyu nasıl ifade etsem
bilemiyorum Tüm bunları 6 Şubat'ta ve
izleyen günlerde acımızı Kolektif olarak
bastırıp ayağa kalkabildiğimiz için
gerçekleştirebildik sonunda yol açık yol
açık
ulaştığımız bölgelerde çok sevgiyle
karşılandı ve analdı kısa adıyla yaya
Yeri geldi yaşanan acılara pansuman Umut
olabildi Bölge Jandarma komutanlıklarına
çok müteşekkiriz Yolumuz hep açık oldu
aynı şekilde depremde yardım
organizasyonlarımız için bize İtimat
edip destek veren tüm arkadaşlarıma
gönüllü genç doktorlara olağanüstü
deprem ve kış koşullarına rağmen dans
etmeye demeden
yardımlarımıza ulaştıran şoförlere ayni
destek Lojistik yardımı yapan tüm kurum
kuruluş insanları çok teşekkür ederiz
tüm ülke olarak içimizi parçalayan Asrın
felaketi birbirinin hiç tanımayan
insanlarımız da bir araya getirdi hep
beraber iyileşmek için ayağa kalktık
çaba ve zamanla iyileşeceğiz
yol açık yol açık olarak geliş satışa
travma yaşayan çocuklara yetişkinlere
sosyal ve psikolojik desteğin yanı sıra
sanatla mesleki yetkinliklerle doğayla
yardımcı olmak istiyoruz bunun için
felaketin ilk gününden beri
hedeflediğimiz projemizi genişletti
kurumsal kimlikle Hatay Defne ve
Samandağ'da Hayat yeniden çiçek açıyor
merkezimize ve merkezimize ve ek
ünitesini kuracağız kayıplarımızı giden
canları yılları yerine koyamayız Ama
yaraları sarmak pandemi ya da iklim
değişikliği gibi küresel boyuttaki
krizleri bile durdurabilmek kolektif bir
çabayla mümkün kötü tecrübeyi iyiye
değiştirmek mutluluğa dönüştürmek mümkün
iyi işler yapmaktan size alıkoyan zaman
zaman dikkatinizi dağıtan negatif
unsurlar süreçler olabilir konuşmaların
başında söylendiği gibi hiçbir yer gül
bahçesi değil
benim gençlere tavsiyem iyilik düşün
hayallerini İnan umudunu Yenile
hareketin iyileştirici dönüştürücü
gücünden istifade et ayağa kalk bugün
burada bizi bir araya getiren ev
sahibimiz Çanakkale organizasyon
komitesini salondaki ve ekrandaki tüm
sevgili izleyicilere sevgi ve saygıyla
selamlıyorum yolunuz yolunuz açık olsun